[Music]
these are just these are adjectives and
these are nouns okay so we're gonna pull
out any two and then we're gonna just
describe Donald Trump and any two so
this is my this is my random the
douchebag infested human air horn Donald
Trump or or constipated bagpipe powered
by farts Donald Trump or it's fun these
have these are actual fortune cookies
I've had America's number-one
jack-o'-lantern in a suit Donald Trump
here you try one all right I'll try one
yeah you read the yellow in hers you
read the yellow one first yeah okay
ten jello deli meat sculpture Donald
Trump yes fun over here people walking
up to me all the time and saying don't
you isn't it great like given that you
are a late-night comic that Donald Trump
is and I was like he just go away
yeah tell jokes
you know what if you know I don't crave
the jokes that will make jokes about
something else I will take that I'll
take that can't wait to see this country
swallowed up in its own [ __ ] but
Donald Trump on the whiteout like it's
not an exciting right it's we don't that
could be fun that could be funny
you